retrouver ou découvrir le centre
aquatique du lac à montigny le
bretonneux
ce mercredi 30 juin la municipalité et
celle de voisins-le-bretonneux organisé
une journée spéciale les habitants
étaient invités à tester trois activités
proposées par le centre et ce
gratuitement
ça fait partie de ces équipements qui
ont été fermées ces nombreux maux
derniers mois ou ré ouvert de façon très
épisodique
donc on a voulu attirer à nouveau nos
usagers qu'ils viennent s'approprier
nouveau l'espace et voir un petit peu ce
qu'on peut leur proposer tant sur le
niveau aquatiques que sur le fitness ou
encore sur la partie où elle laisse le
centre propose de nombreuses activités
même les habitués profite de cette
journée pour découvrir de nouveaux
loisirs
je trouve ça super ça permet de
découvrir l'établissement pour les
personnes qui ne connaissent pas et de
tester des activités je viens à la
piscine pratiquement tous les jours j'ai
un abonnement annuel
alors je fais surtout d agréer des
instruments et du vélo le centre dispose
d'une salle de musculation et d'une
autre dédiée au cardio et la crise
sanitaire a eu un impact sur la pratique
des usagers je pense que la crise a
permis aux gens se rendent compte que
qui peuvent faire beaucoup de choses
tout seul à la maison donc le boom
training il s'est beaucoup démocratisé
après à côté de ça il ya aussi ils sont
aussi rendus compte du besoin en fait
d'être en fait d'être accompagnés dans
leurs pratiques et le besoin de se
dépenser
les abonnements pour le centre sont
disponibles au mois au trimestre ou à
l'année
les habitant de montignez voisins le
bretonneux peuvent profiter d'un tarif
préférentiel